a producer here thinks that they can
make me scream I don't even know the
last time I even scream I get scared of
things really easily now I guess it's
because I witnessed an exorcism well too
actually
if someone tried to scare me I think I
might just laugh I'm the kid who like
hears like noises in the middle of the
night and thinks the world's ending I
can bet anything you will not hear me
scream
I can already guarantee you I'm not
gonna do that well but why not face our
fears let's bring on the screams this
isn't scary
nothing is scary I'm not gonna scream
[Music]
like afraid I'm gonna bow if there's
something was gonna pop up out of the
screen oh come from behind I knew
something like that was gonna happen and
look what did I say
smiling right now I already hate this so
much I feel so vulnerable am I gonna get
bit there's gonna be something painful
or something creepy and crawly there
could be a lot of things that you can be
placing in my hand right now I don't
even want to guess that's just annoying
is this the most annoying challenge so
what do you think the final challenge is
I get kidnapped you are getting
kidnapped your heart's beating really
bad I'm taking you to the scariest
haunted house in New York City why let's
go I hate this so much
No
oh god no no no no when's the scary part
that was hilarious
[Applause]
[Applause]
this is the worst part I'm not nervous
I screamed okay I lost the challenge
[Applause]
[Music]
love mana was scary but I think I need
something a little bit more scream oh
it's incredible
[Music]